good afternoon welcome everybody
um a couple things on the list just to
remember that this meeting
is operating under covert level two so
don't breathe on each other too much um
we will and very shortly just
run around and introduce each other and
that will act as a registrar of who is
here and where you're from
so that's an important thing to be done
under these
trying times um
stephen could you kick us off please
with a karakia thank you
thank you steve so um
as we're under level two there is no
public presence at this meeting
uh and now continuing on with uh an
audio recording
so um committee members if you can just
make sure you use your mics that helps
with that process please
uh any apologies out there today
david ashby will be here a wee bit later
on he's
got another meeting to attend apart from
that
okay alrighty um
cam could you lead off with the
introductions please
sure cameron henderson uh deputy chair
and a community member of the zone
committee
erin harvey community member of the zone
wendy main community member of zone
committee
sandra stewart a waimakariri district
councillor
kiara judith lindsay community member of
the zone committee
uh john cook knight tu huridi ruin
nagari
community member and current chair mr
ridlen could you
carry on with introductions that you're
in please
on my right is murray excellent ecan
facilitator
alrighty any changes to the
registration a register of interest
which we need to record
nothing there really good which brings
us straight
to item three a presentation on the copy
river monitoring which i think is a
combined
presentation between adrian and sophie
from
ecan and wdc
thank you um the um
just two things i've got here is the
first one uh on the last couple of
meetings you uh
um you've been asking for what the
current um
results we've been seeing on salinity
incursions that the kaiapoi river had
been and so this first
there's a graph in your notes here on
the download we did recently of the
salinity logger at the mandeville bridge
in the middle of kaiapoi
um first thing this had been operating
since
um the end of november last year we
finally managed to get into we were
intending to download it
um and but then got defeated by the
covert uh lockdown sort of process it's
taken us a while to get back since
um but so here is the results
unfortunately the logger failed at about
the end of
um about the middle of may but that
still gives us some
sort of six or six or seven months of
data which is probably the critical
period we would normally see
salinity intrusion you can see there
that um pretty much during the periods
at the end of november
in december and early january as per
usual the road there wasn't there hasn't
been any sale on intrusion at the
kaiapoi river
the river river the waimakariri river
flows stay quite high there
there were a couple of brief events of
cylinder of salinity moving up the
coyote river in january but
otherwise as per other years we're
seeing discrete periods of uh
saline water moving up the kaibui river
in
february march and april um that are
largely associated with
low flows in the waimakariri river but
also modified to some extent by the
extent of the tide heights
particularly when we're getting those
king tides or the higher tides periods
um so really this adds to the previous
couple of years of data we've got on
here and we're really lining up hoping
to get this
sort of converted into a sort of model
and then if you in the near future when
the nemo stuff we've been talking to
are available to sort of chew this up
into a more productive model that'll
make it useful
we certainly certainly the winter
there's been a
low flow there's been quite a low flow
period in sort of july and august
so it's disappointing that the logger
wasn't operating over that period
but we have put another logger in that
will be collecting that sort of data
for the last couple of weeks and that'll
probably illustrate that these low flows
we've been seeing are probably allowing
salinity to come up the river
in midwinter at this year as well
so that's probably that's as far as
we've got with salinity monitoring
a second second paragraph i've got
there is water quality monitoring of the
kaiapoi river and i've just put a
paragraph there to illustrate that
routine water quote that
if we were to routine routinely water
quality sample the kaikohe river
we'd pretty much follow a similar site
at the mandeville bridge there
with continuously water quality
monitoring data to actually illustrate
what was happening under the
complex sort of situation of twice a day
tides
plus backflow of the waimakariri river
plus
all the other influences on a very
dynamic river like this
we've sort of scoped and costed it out
and we
hope to have that we hope to get the
approval in that in this this year
but really it's the only way to really
get
important sort of water quality data on
a river like this like in the middle of
kaiapoi
that sort of teases apart all of these
influences
and that's pretty much where i've got to
any questions on those two
items
yes sorry me i just wonder is there has
there already been
been any biological monitoring on
particularly the banks
of the chi poi in this area i'm thinking
when i went there with jessica when she
was our biodiversity obviously we found
mud crabs there
and just wonder if anybody's looking at
that
we opportunistically noted it in our
previous report we haven't been
routinely going back
and sort of doing that but yes you're
right mud crabs and mud crab burrows are
probably the biggest indicator of saline
influence that they arrive into that
environment i'm not sure
make whether very district anything
so you say i have also looked at trying
to figure out how far up i can see the
borrowing
mud crabs and then you're up to at least
the cam or blood
gate there are tunneling crabs so
there's a great you know biotic
indices of where that salinity is coming
to and there has been question having
questions around whether those
that can destabilize the banks um which
is yeah it could lead to some trees
falling in or some issues there
adrian a question um on
what sort of equipment would be needed
to
um to measure the flows
within the system that's
sort of crucial to the
scope of the data that i think the
community
and and would welcome um some hard data
on this
so what sort of gear would you require
to put in
um to measure flows as well as i mean
you're talking about
water quality other parameters here but
what about flow
i think you can just stew it um
measuring flow within a tidal waterway
is
well it's very difficult now i'm not a
hydrologist myself i've been liaising
with my colleagues on
on this sort of subject but um certainly
silver stream the um the hocus stream
the cusp custom drain and and to some
extent up
the cam have all got flow recorders on
them
and it would be the best indication
would be summing those sort of flows
and making an estimate as to whether
there was any further gains below those
um certainly in a very dynamic tidal
environment i don't think you could i'm
not sure i doubt if you would be able to
measure um
flow itself at the recorder site we're
proposing at the moment we certainly
will be
incorporating into that equipment a
level gauge so we more accurately
measure
the sort of water levels in the tidal
tidal influences
and things like that rather than
inferring them from tide charts
but i think we'd be relying on flow
measurements from the upstream sites and
summing them together
is it possible to put an equipment
downstream of those
those tributaries to actually measure
the title well the title flow
both at high and low tide and does he
can have that sort of equipment
i haven't really thought too much about
that certainly i would have to talk to
my colleague
my sort of hydrometric colleagues about
this and what value it would uh
offer us um but certainly you know we'd
be starting with the title amplitude and
measuring that
very accurately to begin with anyway um
i'm not sure of how the value it would
give us trying to determine what sort of
peak title tidal flows we'd be getting
but
probably and i suspect where you're
coming from is is
discussing the flushing of the flushing
of the of the of the waterway and what
the residence time
and from a water quality perspective i'd
be being more concerned about
how long it takes that nutrient-rich
water to be flushed out to the
waimakariri
and how long it stays in the system and
probably
the most relevant way to deal with that
is probably doing dye studies
in the river putting a die tracer quite
quite high up in the system
in the measuring how long it takes for
that to be extinguished out of the river
in other words how many days you'd still
be detecting it
before it was flushed out at the bottom
end of the river and once again this
sort of logger technology we're putting
in
we'd be able to measure that sort of
that sort of measurement to make that
sort of estimate but once again we'd be
talking to
sort of modelers and hydrologists about
that as well
um so adrian you said you were i'm going
to put in i presume another logger which
will measure
water quality in terms of nitrates and
pee and that sort of thing and
will that be going into the main stem of
the kai poi
or will it be going into the tributaries
and is there any benefit
in having it in either or either
yes thank you um at this stage what i'm
proposing here is a single site
but it's basically the same place we've
been doing the salinity monitoring on
the mandeville bridge which is just
upstream
of the main william street bridge and we
and what i'd propose is we'd be putting
two different bloggers on there
a nitrate logger which is the big issue
people talk about in terms of
the nitrogen coming down and we already
we already possess
a nitrate logger in-house that is
suitable for at that site that can cope
with some salinity as well
the other the other piece of equipment
we put in would be a
multi-channel logger that is similar to
what we'd often put
in like in taiwan like ella's mirror or
like forsyth as well which measures the
sort of green
the chlorophyll a and the greenness of
the water and the turbidity of the water
and
ph and dissolved oxygen and things like
that so there would be a single logger
that would measure all of those
parameters
and if we'd have those two situated
together
on the river and then we could then we
could correlate that with
with backflow of waimakariri river water
the tidal
tidal levels and the upstream flows to
sort of tease apart
where what what's generating the worst
water quality
and sort of therefore where the best
benefits are for
suggesting improvements to the river
thanks adrian so have you got anything
like that
yeah just a little bit to add to what
wdc my micro district council
is looking towards um for management in
the
kaiapoi river specifically so it is as
everyone knows coming up to
our long-term plan time frames and it is
um we only have one more year of the
official kaiapoi river rehabilitation
working program which has had the tidal
plantings to
some terrestrial plantings um
then there's been the dredging works
that our council has completed
so some of these things are coming to a
natural completion but we are
looking forward um to the future of what
um
now might be in the in the ltp so
i'm trying to form that we also have the
um
some work by jacobs limited which has
been looking at sea level rise and
coastal inundation modeling you know the
hydrodynamic rather than just a bathtub
model we actually now have
something that looks about how it
happens to groundwater levels um
and how things actually move so that
really has helped us in the kaiapoi area
to
to see where we might have more of an
easter egg area rather than a
river area and you know the short
medium to long-term future so that i
guess really is something that
a commission you might be interested to
see that modelling it is um
public information of course um yeah so
i like what we could do for example is
continue projects that were in the
kaiapoi river rehabilitation program
underneath the zipper there's obviously
several recommendations with it fits
um yeah this is keen to hear your
thoughts if you've got any questions on
how to
continue this program
um thanks sophie so the jacobs um
report you say it's currently being
distributed
but you say it's can we have a
presentation on that i
thought it would be very interesting to
this group yeah i think
there are specific uh public meetings
that will be happening um
sorry my phones the computer's ringing
so uh the there will be public uh
meetings uh specifically on this topic
um i think jared's in the audience who
might know the exact dates sometimes
with the
um jacob's modelling they call the
coastal foundation
the natural hazards modeling work
yeah i think it's october end of
september or early october i think
and sorry as part of that then so they
modeled the hydrodynamics of the
coastline
but they didn't come up the river the
estuary in order to do that it's a
multi-part uh thinking of the question
whether the coastline is degrading or
degrading and good news for us is that
it's actually moving outwards uh
surprisingly question is moving in um
there's also um so tsunami risk that was
that's separate but i think that's um
you know it is one of our natural
hazards so fault lines
flooding the flood mapping was redone so
there's a whole package that's actually
really really interesting that i
would recommend this count this
committee to to have a briefing about so
i can organize
it yeah yeah i'd like to request that mr
chairman who's
i would like to request that we have a
briefing on the jacobs report please
natural hazard modeling of the jacobs
report
i'm sure murray can help facilitate that
any further questions
sandra um
i've got uh yep if you just hold for one
second because i just want to
overlay pretty much everything that
both members have put forward so
september 3rd i think which was last
thursday the mps freshwater
kicked off and i'm sure every
council member or member of the farming
community
or member of the public slowly trying to
get their head around
the ramifications of what the central
government is now asking us
particularly in terms of monitoring
follows on quite strongly with
what we and our zipper have put forward
we want to know
what's happening in our environment
faster
and in real time if possible so
definitely if you can forward that
program
as you're into to make it happen next
week would be wonderful
if not the week after but we really need
that real-time monitoring
given the fact i think we have a bathing
suit 100 meters downstream at the carpa
river
bridge um that's notified in the plan so
um and the requirements that they are
putting there for e coli
are basically saying it has to be tested
daily at the levels that
that river is operating at at the moment
so
definitely work that needs to be done so
sandra did you want to
happy to move that we receive um this
update but
also want to add in and it just endorses
what the chairman's just said that
we ask ecan as a matter of urgency to
install not only the um the nitrate
logger which i understand adrian's
already done but this
multi-channel logger that will measure
all other water quality parameters in
the
in the kaipu river and i'm also very
keen
that he can take advice and
install some measurement of flow
within the main stem of the kaipu river
i think it's essential that
we move from anecdotal information on
all these parameters including flow
to trying to get some hard data in the
next
year or so and
[Music]
as um as we all know the kaiapoi river
is a
receiving environment for most of the
well all of the tributary streams on the
um
on the south side of the
region the district and we have um
absolutely no hard data on what are the
dynamics
of quality and flow within this
river system and i distinguish it from
as
as ecan has done
in the zipper implant change seven
this is from the confluence of the
tributary streams down to the confluence
with the
waimakariri the main stem of the river
the data is virtually non-existent
apart from the
monitoring that takes place laowa
on the laowa site for fecals at the
cure boating ramp so seeing this
river is under the new
nps qualifies for just about
every element of degradation it needs to
be given
an absolute paramount priority
that some hard data is
is gathered urgently and as the chairman
said it is a designated
bathing spot at the um
at the william street bridge and every
summer
we have uh kids leaping off
um into as you're well aware i'm very
highly contaminated water
so i just urge the
the zone committee to support the
addition to this recommendation here
that as a matter of urgency we request
ecan install all its fancy gear
and report back on a regular basis
to us if it's every 15 minutes
um i'd like to see that we we have a
report every quarter
and i think that fits with the zipper
recommendations
and also it is a zipper recommendation
that we
gather some data on the stretch of river
so ask the rest of the committee members
for their support on this edition thank
you
thank you sander do i have a seconder
for that very long motion
i was speaking to it as well okay
that that'll do for now oh my question
is just around
um you know if we're if he can are
investing and monitoring it's got to
have a purpose
and be for a reason and
given what adrian was saying before
about
using the tributaries to measure flow
and
not really seeing a clear purpose for
doing
um monitoring further down the main stem
i think that perhaps we need ecam to go
back to the subject
and work out whether there would be any
benefit from additional monitoring on
the main stem such as what sandra was
talking about
so sorry so you're specifically talking
volume they're not quality um well we've
already covered the quality in terms of
the two loggers
or three loggers that are going to be in
so we're really talking about flow
flow yeah
and committees support the installation
of the second
logger which is what i'm aiming for
that we actually support ikea
in that case i would second the support
for putting in the
nitrates and the multi-channel loggers
as you've described
patreon thank you thank you we have a
motion a second
all those in favor
all right against carrie
thank you very much
i just wonder um obviously we've moved
through
that yeah i just wonder whether adrian
or tim might be able to
give a comment on what our next steps is
council will have to be in terms of
implementing mps and looking at
monitoring more broadly and whether um
you're better off to look at
whether the zone company sees puts an
intention that you want to be involved
or have part of that conversation as we
as a council will have to
look at that to me or addre
at all if these if we've even turned our
heads to that yet we've had a lot to
process in the last couple of weeks
yeah perhaps if i could just comment on
it in terms of
the what's come through from the action
for healthy waterways
that nothing has changed in the sense of
where to monitor it's what to monitor
that has changed so it has introduced
new parameters
of which quite a few of them we actually
monitor already
that there are a couple that we don't
i'm thinking of the
ecosystem health and the fish in
particular
um but the in terms of where to monitor
so what i'm getting at there is you know
the kaipoi as a place to monitor within
the zone
the mps doesn't get down to that level
of
specif isn't that specific
um the
which then comes down to what
has been specified in the plans so under
plane change seven is the kaiapoi
a separate
monitoring unit or not and i'm just not
sure i'm asking that question because i
don't know
if it is then there is certainly the
expectation that all of the parameters
that are mentioned
in the nps would be monitored or it's
not an expectation they have to be um
but as i say quite a lot of those are
already monitored
so uh there's just a few so so i guess
what i'm really getting at
um council of hands is that
our thoughts have been more about what
is being monitored rather than where
now that's not to say that's not a good
question it's just that we haven't
put a lot of thought into that yet i
don't know if you want to do it
part of part of what has driven this is
the zipper recommendation since the
zipper recommendation 40 sort of
explicitly
identified the kaiapoi river and the
degraded water body
water quality of the cowboy river for
for that is driven in many respects this
recommendation
um the other issue i would clarify at
this point is
once you get down into tidal waters like
the cowboy river and i was talking about
residence time um the water quality
through the middle of kaiapoi differs
considerably from the water quality of
the contributing
tributaries because they are flowing
waters and the kaiapoi river is
tidal so it's behaving more like a lake
and the water's there long enough to
start
growing into our into sort of green
water and turbid water from algal blooms
and things like that that's why it
deserves
quite a separate monitoring technique
basically monitoring it more like a lake
than like a river
and in some respects um
the action for fresh waters hasn't
explained
is says hasn't explicitly
required us to monitor um it's not
explicit on where to monitor but it does
at times talk more about
looking at integrated rivers and
interconnections with the sea so it
probably is focusing more on
down into the areas we haven't focused
on before
which is tidal waterways like this and
that may we
may therefore be more sensitive nutrient
environments because of that sort of
lake like nature
any further comment on item three
lovely thanks adrian sophie just before
we moved to item four
just for the record of the meeting just
want to note that
two gentlemen have joined us tim davey
from w
uh from ecan um and gerald cleary from
wdc
right murray item four committee updates
what would you like to update us on
thank you michael um the
first of the updates is our regular
update on proposed plan change seven um
the key points to note here is
the uh confirmation of the hearing
on the 28th of september and as you'll
see it'll run
for uh over a five-week period but not
consecutively through um
through to the fourth of december the
other significant thing for for people
in this zone
is that judo uh covert
lockdown requirements and the fact that
um the panel chair david shepard is
based in melbourne which makes it even
trickier
um it needs to be done uh
by a streaming setup so there isn't a
location within
the waimakariri district that's been
identified that could hold the hearing
and provide that service so the
the actual venues are low uh listed here
in terms of
um uh they'll be in the in the city
effectively in christchurch city and and
in timaru
so that's uh unfortunate for people
residing here in the district but it's
uh one of the difficulties with the
panel chair being based in melbourne
um so i don't know if there's any
questions with regards to that
but the major changes from the previous
month
if not i'll move on to the
regional committee and i can perhaps
hand over to carolyn
who has provided a report in the meeting
papers
yep um we'll just take that as read um
there's no
um workshop this month so the next
meeting will be
um in october i think the second tuesday
of october
um were there any questions regarding
the minutes
sorry yes caroline um i
can't remember where it was in relation
to but there was some discussion as to
the fact there are no zone up
no time for zone committee updates
was that um ever discussed or
seen as a problem or was that at the
last meeting you talked about that
anyway
i can't because of the gaps i've lost
track of that discussion
yeah it was actually something that
murray was going to follow up on
yes i have relayed that um to
my colleague who uh facilitates that
committee so yeah it's certainly um
ted howard from the kaikoura zone that i
also facilitate with it's
shared caroline's
you know con frustration and also seeing
the value that that's one of the things
that the
regional committee provides is that
connection across
the whole obviously the whole region and
getting to share
issues or identify new things so just
ted certainly reinforced that as well so
i've passed that on
so hopefully that will be something that
um
is a an attribute of foreign means but i
guess there's still
some deliberations going on in terms of
the regional committee and its
role and purpose so i guess we we wait
to hear from you carolyn really in terms
of how that
progresses
there's nothing more on that item item
three is the
land water committee uh papers that's
and report that
i've provided is item 4.2 from the 13th
august meeting so i guess with um
councillor stewart and sophie and juror
in the room i don't know if there are
any questions with regards to that i
included the full report just just
thinking it would be if
you used to have that and see that as a
reference for you
uh the next story oh sorry the pineville
planting is that part of not that's not
that's
not a gender issue for us that's only
okay
question on that yeah um
the item there i was just interested in
the actual on the figure figure one on
page 20
20 something that's indecipherable
anyway
um just which is the direction of flow i
mean
from so it comes both gumtree and
layman's road springs
are both springs that then come onto the
roadside
onto the side of fernside
and then do the cross
and then it all just parallels it just
goes runs beside
fell inside the road at that point sorry
it's just for clarification
don't know the area well do you know
sophie
yeah follow the follow-up plan side road
did they go onto the property that's uh
not roadside another private property
okay that was just a minor thing thank
you
carrying on if there aren't any more
questions on that one
we've got the zone committee's working
group so this is just
an opportunity for a quick update from
each of the working groups so
i can perhaps hand over to cam on my
right to start with with the landcare
working group of which he's provided
a short summary
ah thanks murray yeah there's i really
just take that as read just covers a
couple of key points that we've been
progressing with
our landcare working group um over the
last few weeks so
probably in addition to that we did
complete a walk last friday over some
properties
around the spring heads of silverstream
and have been yeah talking ideas and
options in science so
hopefully there's more progress on that
um yeah in the coming weeks
sorry so just typo is that the 14th of
september
just for the record you met on friday
the 14th
uh of august august thank you last month
okay
i mean oh yeah august thank you
so i just had a question kim about that
paragraph underneath point
four what what's that around
that's the as a reminder but um i guess
it was
definitely more directed at the um zone
committee members around
the potential discussion we had
originally formed as a working group
around just general engagement with
various groups
with a focus on farming to start with
but it was envisaged to go out to
you know the general public urban public
that sort of thing as well
now we have uh evolved into
something that's probably quite
different to the original intention
around creating a land care group so
there's potential scope that if we
wanted to refocus on
you know urban engagement and other
groups that there might be scope for
another working group or
somewhere else there so just to
emphasize that
we're not looking at that as one of our
core functions at this stage
thank you cam i can probably hand over
to judith now i've just
handed out the summary notes from the
biodiversity working group thank you
um yes the notes of the record
um so the biodiversity working group was
established in
august um and we're not a super
committee we call ourselves a working
group because we're a mix of members
and staff from ecan ecologists staff
from economic career district council
which is proven in three meetings to be
a really useful way of
getting to know what's going on and
getting a good understanding of each
other
um we met last friday and the main
things we
talked about were some getting some zone
for um
so sorry drone photography of projects
or project areas in the zone um
john cook is a expert drone operator and
he's going to take some video and still
photographs
um starting with the cam with town if a
river between floodgates and rebels road
and the idea being to get um sorry once
owner permissions are completed
to get some baseline information prior
to restoration
we'll start later this year we talked
about
ims projects and
projects that will be brought to this
committee for approval or ratification
at the next meeting but just to
have a preliminary discussion about the
pros and cons and the values
and to give feedback to zipper when
she's dealing with landowners
we talked about zipper implementation
updates and some of the changes in
projects that are happening in
waimakariri district and how funding and
other opportunities might arise
one of the ideas which we've talked
about a couple of meetings is the idea
of
setting up a an award that would
specifically recommend
recognize environmental conservation or
biodiversity work by individuals or
groups in the district
and sort of similar to the community
service awards but more
perhaps project related but definitely
much more tailored to the environment
um there it's a great i think it's a
great idea but the actual practicalities
and the process
and the um the topics and the funding
and any criteria for awarding it are
obviously going to take us a bit longer
to
um to discuss and so that will be at the
next meeting but if anybody's got any
ideas
um particularly what the prize the award
might be whether it's cash or just a
nice certificate and a cup of tea um no
i need to
sort of discuss that one um
kakariki trust is a trust operating in
white
and sewen district um setting up
carrying out
habitat and biodiversity restoration
projects quite well
very well established there and there's
been some
discussions between kate and the trust
about them operating
or coming into waimakariri district
and obviously getting a much you know
having much more involvement by one like
very district people but
using their expertise and experience so
and that's something that the
biodiversity group is continuing to
discuss
um taranaki reserve there was a planting
day in august and
john and sophie helped planting
in the reserve there and there's going
to be a second planting date
probably on the 26th of august thank you
sorry 26th of september um zone
committee members are
going along and we're going to encourage
as many people as possible to
come and join um you know we really need
to get on site
and to get out to the meeting rooms and
get down
into the community so that seemed like a
good opportunity
um and finally the saltwater catchment
group
meeting was held and caroline i think
we'll report on this separately but
um there were there was interest in
biodiversity and water quality
monitoring expressed by the group there
and some of the history of the catchment
and again the biodiversity working group
discussed that
and we'll keep in touch with that
catchment group um
to try and bring the two things together
and so the group will meet
next on the first thursday the first of
october um which we prior to our next
meeting so we'll
repeat this reporting then thank you any
questions
our third working group um which i've
just
just noted is uh what we've called the
coastal catchments working group which
is
being led variably by caroline so i'll
hand it over to carolyn just for
an update thanks murray um so we had
a meeting on the 25th of august um
for the saltwater creek catchment um
31 people came along representing about
24 properties
we ran through the beef and lamb
catchment meeting template
and got some really good feedback from
the group and in the conclusion at the
meeting was that they did want to form a
catchment group
um so we're
sort of getting next steps ready for a
meeting again on the 6th of october
to talk through quite a few things
yeah so it's all looking really good
thanks caroline that's great um the next
item
is communications and engagement so
angus has provided
a summary of the the significant media
coverage in the last
um last month with particular focus on
the
uh the removal of trees in the ashley
rakahuri regional park
that the committee will be familiar with
welcome back david who joins the meeting
you're right david um
so look yeah the angus has provided the
links to those
uh media foods uh i don't know if
there's anything else
or any questions first of all perhaps
from the committee and whether there's
anything angus would like to
further update the committee on
sorry i'm i mean was the most major
major event in ranger over the last
couple of weeks um
what is happening on the ground i mean
i'm do you think you might be able to
help
what is happening to that area
now do you know sorry
i don't know a huge amount of detail but
i do know that yeah there's consultation
with the um
with the community and there will be
it'll be being grasped and there'll be
some planning going in
um as an aside to that i also know that
staff we're meeting
wdc and environment canterbury tomorrow
actually just around that um
consultation process for
similar things in the future make sure
the right
steps are followed yeah but we'll get a
better
picture perhaps we can make it part of
the um
the braided river workshop next time
around yeah
i think there'll be some scope for
native plant i mean
native planting yeah just get it i mean
because i did write the first engineers
handbook recam
river engineer's handbook and that did
include you know planting things that
native and will go flat when the flood
comes so it is possible
so great thank you so i'll find out more
for you
thanks andrew the next item
is um the action for healthy waterways
so
what we've included here is
[Music]
an update that i had
at the time of preparing the papers
there is
and angus may want to come up and
speak to this a little bit further but i
believe there's a more substantive
update now
which probably subscribes what's in the
paper
but we can provide that obviously it's
uh
as we discussed earlier you know an
ongoing area of work for
further understanding the implications
of it and um as noted in the
in the meeting papers it's um it's come
into force
as of the 3rd of september so uh we're
in play
at this point so i don't know if there's
any questions with regards to that
and whether angus or anyone would like
to add any
further update to what's in the papers
perhaps if i could just clarify what
that means by in play
um so so there are different aspects to
the action for healthy waterways and i
know
quite a few of you are all over this and
know it but there is the
national policy statement there is the
national environmental statement
and then there are the changes to the
regulations around
in the rma around stock exclusion it's
the
nes the national environmental standard
for fresh water which is in play
from the 3rd of september so that's what
was because
now i should say that nps is but the nps
sets a higher framework from which
plans have to line up with it
so the rules or they're not rules the
the guidance that is in the national
policy statement
are then required to be fitted in with
um
land water regional plan is the case for
canterbury
into the future so that that's what i
meant when i said earlier about the
monitoring that is specified in the nps
doesn't instantly have to be done today
it has to be
part of what's set out and plans how
you're going to do it
and you know how it lines up with the
objectives of plans and
and things like that whereas the
national environmental standard
does come into force but i would just
add
um one thing that is important to
realize that um
so the rules particularly around winter
grazing
um so one of the things about that
is the requirement to have a consent to
farm and and um
there has been some information
come recently or so their legal opinion
was sort by environment southland around
what that actually means
in terms of when do you require a
consent and particularly to do with
um cam you have to help me the legal
term but um
for rights of use yeah
yeah um and so and what that
has said is that as i mean i know a lot
of you know this
kind of repeating it but for those that
don't the
um the requirement
basically says that you've got six
months
from the third of september for it to
start
uh you need to and then you've got a
further six months to actually
have your concern is that the right way
have i got that the right way and i'm
just trying to think
i'm just gonna remember it through the
top note
the rule for wintergrazing doesn't come
in place until may next year and so once
the rules are placed you have six months
of existing use rights until
you must comply yes yes sorry that's
that's absolutely where i came i'd click
on that so the
the under the uh nes the rule comes into
effect six months from
the third of september and then there is
six months under existing use rights
and that's basically to allow time for
it to be worked through as to um what
consents required and that's a
particularly in canterbury that is the
issue as to what consents are required
because
some are required under our current
rules and we're still
working through around what that
actually looks like in terms of
what's required under the nes over and
above
um anything that might be in our current
rules
so so there's the the nes it does
come into effect but the national policy
statement
it comes into effect but what it means
is that we now have to have our plans
lining up
now that then immediately raises the
question that i know he's been asked
before about where does pc7 sit under
that
the answer to that is um that the
hearing commissioners need to take it
into consideration
but it doesn't have to line up
absolutely with it
and this is partly to do with they can
only make changes to do with things that
have been submitted
on and things like this but they have to
make the best attempt
to make it line up but it doesn't have
to be literally lined up
with the the current nps because it was
notified before
the cmbs this is a problem we've had all
the time in canterbury when we've tried
to get things in place
and then national policy statements have
changed 2011 2014
but they're on 14 17 and 20.
can i just ask i guess based on those
timelines tim that anything that doesn't
line up and plan change seven according
to the current rules needs to be
addressed by the end of 2024
notified by the end of 2024 anyway
that's absolutely right
that's the time line and what we are
trying to work through at the moment as
a council
um is how that will be done will that be
done at a sub-regional level or will it
be done at a
cross region and some of that depends on
you know how much change is involved and
uh you know what's required so we
haven't
that certainly hasn't been decided yet
by council how that would be done
sorry one more question and perhaps this
might be directed towards councillor
hands too
is there any indication around the
involvement in of the zone committee in
that process given that there is a
fairly strong emphasis on consultation
and collaboration within the wording of
the mps itself
in other words when we're developing our
action plans should this be
quite a considerable chunk of that
action plan given the type time frames
um as tim said there's still a lot of
ongoing discussions
uh certainly there is a sentiment within
the room that would like to continue to
work with communities
but it all depends where it all lands
and what it looks like in terms of
how we make those decisions and in
resourcing and all that sort of thing
you'll appreciate um just been through
10 years of
writing plans and it's an expensive
exercise and take in
in collaboration has been hard
the sentiment of working with the
community is very much still there
with most councillors i wouldn't be
remiss
it wouldn't be wrong in saying that but
there may be some
further decisions to come but any
advocacy around
the way in which you would like to see
that as a community or as a zone
committee i think would be appreciated
and
be welcomed
yeah i mean councillor hans is
absolutely right i think
i guess the only thing i'd add to that
is it's you know it's really difficult
to see us going back
into a full pc7 type of thing
for this um but at the same time there
is certainly a desire
to be working with community around it
and it's a
it's a real tension particularly with
those time frames
so just one more question tim
uh just in terms of of who
is working with from the environment
canterbury in terms of with the
government
to see how to see how these policies
going to work out because i understand
that
minister parker has established a
working group
with the regional councils so who would
who from environment canterbury is
is on that working group
the key person from a staffing
perspective is nadine
domesey who's the chief operating
officer
you probably know nadine she's involved
in the freshwater
implementation group stephanie as chief
executive is also
involved in i just get my groups a
little bit make stuff i must confess but
she is involved
in one as well and i'm just trying to
remember
yeah and i mean it's a good question
because um
you know it's come at a time of
considerable change with environment
canterbury but we've we've really tried
to stay in there
and it's been through nadine and now
with stephanie confirmed in the position
that's meant that she really is firmly
in that seat as well so we
we are really trying to stay in that
space as much as possible
thank you tim i appreciate you
clarifying what i meant by and play
quite a lot yeah
[Music]
um
so just capturing that for the record
angus is just highlighting that there's
more comms to come around this and
also integrating with other groups
yeah and there's some on the website now
for those that are listening and keen to
follow up
the next item under committee updates
item 7
is provides the committee with an update
on the zone committee review
so at the previous uh meeting and
workshop that
the committee had in august there was an
opportunity to provide some feedback
on the or proposed review that's
occurring
and and proposed changes to the terms of
reference
and the introduction of letter of shared
priorities what's included
in the meeting papers is the
waimakariri district council report
which follows on from the committee's
feedback and
was presented to the council
i think on the
was it the first of september so
whether councillor stewart or sophie
want to add anything or if there are any
questions with regards to
the report that the waimakariri district
council
has received as part of the review
process
okay thanks moving on it's just the
final action points
um from the previous meeting so we had
the uh the mkt
report which uh hopefully the committee
will get a hard copy
and with the emitting papers um that was
asked for circulation we also
had the discussion at the previous
meeting around the the lower website
but following on from that discussion
[Music]
chairman blackwell noted that there were
those
sites that weren't being monitored as
they had previously
so we've noted that as an ongoing point
of follow-up
and i don't know if adrian at all wants
to speak to it we just noted that
that's something to to follow up with
niwa who do the
monitoring of those two sites so adrian
does look like he's
murray um both tim davey and myself both
followed up with the administrator at um
why that data at waimakariri old highway
bridge was not showing up on the lava
website
whereas the gorge bridge data was as we
noted both that data is all
generated from the niwa national rivers
water quality monitoring networks so we
don't own the data
they provide it to lara what we found
out was there was a link
broken in terms of the old highway
bridge data we we discussed that with
the administrator at lawa they've
endeavoured to
fix that link and they assure us that as
of september
that data will be being downloaded back
onto the website again and so should be
it should be up this month
i haven't checked whether it is today
yet but they've assured us they've
fixed that link it's probably worth
saying that uh ecan has
been paying for these newer national
rivers water quality network sites for
the last year or so
we're probably going to take them over
so they may well come under our umbrella
so that'll be
one less step for to have these sort of
errors in the future but
we're pretty much assured that we hope
the data should be displayed this month
and it'll be up to speed again
thank you adrian um in the final point
we've
um followed up at the start of the
meeting um
in terms of the presentation by adrian
on the club
river salinity data logging
that be the updates any further
questions
sorry absolutely the question i guess
for sophie on the mkt
report um on the floodgates um
just in there is a quite brief
assessment of the proposal and i guess
it might be for
you as well pata and john um
the next last bullet point on
page two is that the tidegate will
change the location the saltwater ledge
a saltwater wedge ieb area where fresh
water over less
fresh i think it should be salt water
overlays fresh water
um and that would likely affect
inaugural spawning areas in the vicinity
and i wondered if there's anything in
the proposal that anti-identified that
that actually would it could positively
just
move it's only going to move the salt
water wedge and so the
inunda spawning will simply probably
possibly move
it's not necessarily a detrimental
effect but it actually could be positive
because you get better habitat because
he
actually creating habitat and managing
it and i just wondered if
that was ever taken into consideration
in the proposal and therefore in
the assessment it just seemed possibly a
slightly negative thing on what could be
could have become a positive aspect of
the proposal
so it wasn't an assessment of effects
that that report it was saying these are
the things that the
present feasibility study would look at
so okay yeah it was
because there's so many it was basically
listing these are the kinds of things we
need to look at
but he wasn't looking at them no no
because it's it's a big
thing to say we're working to what it
would move to a place where the banks
were steeper
or yeah so who's going to follow up on
that how does it um well thanks to this
report
yes so the response the reply
report from nkt was that the ruling were
opposed to the proposal proposal yeah
yeah so that that means that our council
the motion that was passed by the
utilities and voting committee was that
we would not proceed
either or environment canterbury didn't
want to
for that feasibility study to proceed so
that's we needed the study to proceed
yes so it's a feasibility study that we
were proposing not okay not
and so this this hasn't actually gone to
our utilities and roading committee
again uh what was it land of water
committee
yeah yeah so it will go back that we
will present this report to our council
it hasn't actually been officially
presented
okay all right yeah and so i according
to the motion that was made
at the previous when it was presented we
think the council will no longer proceed
okay so just a curiosity who
commissioned the report
so so that was commissioned by wdc or
um to consult with the kaisaki
representatives for
so i understand that then um
but if it was coming from the zone
committee then there's no need to engage
mkt because you had two mandated
representatives at the table
just for future reference
i mean it just seemed that it was it was
seems quite negative i mean i can
appreciate that could be a problem
on the things i know something about
they seem to be quite negative without
actually looking at positives and i just
wondered if that was because
wdc actually hadn't thought about the
positives to offer them in the first
place
but i'm not just because it's still such
early days
they haven't even thought of those is
that right yeah so are you looking at
sorry this is the both the mkt report
but there was a previous report that i
put together so it's that that that's
where
they were assessing uh no no we didn't
say this is this i
tried to be unbiased so this is the
information about the project and what
we think it will cost and some of the
potential effects which could be
positive or negative yeah but we just
need to consider these effects
so i wasn't trying to say which way no
but
things and so yeah it was a
project a report for context but it
wasn't for
for them to make a decision based on
they actually sought independent advice
and i think that stated in that mkt
report that they did went to came to
meetings because of there was extra
information needed that they needed
more than just two reports provided to
each other yeah yeah exactly
thank you
oh yeah any further questions
all right so we have a recommendation
that the waimakariri's own committee
received these updates
for its information and with reference
to the committee's
2020 2021 work program
and engagement priorities do i have
a mover and a secondary please
cam thank you john
kerry well all those in favor better not
rush that one
sorry yep
alrighty item five confirmation of
minutes
of the previous zone meeting on
the 3rd of august 2020.
which i think we all have copies of so
um
again we have a recommendation that we
confirm these minutes
as a true inaccurate record can i have a
mover please
yep secondary
caroline thank you all those in favor
all right
mata's rising
that was easy right general business
all right caroline
came all right we're used to that
i just had it like a um correction is
now the time for corrections
it's normally under matters arising
there you go okay
we do need some training don't we and
well i do um so just on page 69
um paragraph 7.2
um that was about the loss of the
shingle removal in the ashley river
how that would impact the nesting river
birds rather than the quarry itself
yeah thanks
any other matters
all righty general business item six
murray have you got any general business
all right
anything from the floor staff members
anything you'd like to raise
just because this meeting is going to be
too short so i'll ask a question to
keep things going um this might be a
benefit tim or anyone else who's got
expertise around the table
the um the new regulations around
freshwater specifically save fresh water
arguably we've got some waterways that
sometimes have fresh water sometimes
saltwater
what is that what are the implications
of that for targets
in our zone or in canterbury in general
or are they even doomed to waterway are
they deemed an history or a lake as you
were saying
i think they're all hiding
perhaps perhaps we could table that and
that might just be uh
an update tim's looking brave yeah
what i can't remember is what what it
actually says about the coastal if it
adds anything different to
so the new if it adds anything different
which is very much in the
fresh water environment i don't
think it does but at the same time it
doesn't preclude
you know any council working in that
environment so
it is predominantly about fresh water
it is about
being integrated and you know the whole
concept of tamannaah to why
um a lot of that is about integration
across a range of different
environments so i think there would be
an expectation
that it would be working but it doesn't
get down to talk about specific ways
that those could be addressed is it
i mean how do you feel about that adrian
i'm just trying to
yeah i think we're still trying to come
to terms with it the the
the national policy state of freshwater
management certainly does
in in the early early sections sort of
talk about the concept of kirito
and integrated rivers
and sort of saying the connection and
actually mentions the connection to the
sea
so it's i think it's it's in a broad
sense encouraging us to look at rivers
right down to their connection to the
sea and even to their effect on the sea
but it's
sort of sort of a high level
i guess my question's probably more
around because you're right the
principles do seem to apply to waterways
no matter where they are really but it's
around particularly some of the measures
you know they're talking about 90
of protection for 90 of indigenous
freshwater species but when you've got a
saltwater environment obviously that's
quite difficult or if it's
you know tidal it could be quite
difficult so i guess it was just
probably more around the application of
targets for some of the
um the bottom lines and particularly for
us where we should we be aiming and
and what parts would fall under a
coastal plan versus a
uh you know a planetary seven or lander
water regional plant
i'm also just wondering thinking of um
salmon fisheries
you need a license within 50 or 500
metres of the mouth
yeah so that kind of gives you some
direction around the fresh water yeah
i've just done a word search on the mps
for everyone
um there is only four mentions of
coastal marine area within
the document but one of them
is that receiving environment includes
but is not limited to any water body
river lake wetland
aquifer and the coastal marine area
including estuaries
but a wetland within an eastern area
isn't considered
within a marine area isn't considered a
freshwater wetland it's got separate
rules so yeah that's it will be included
in the receiving environment
but there's not anything further than
that
yeah a brackish gray is that
um perhaps i could then take the
opportunity to
talk a little bit well i'll ask adrian
actually to talk a little bit about
um some work that we are just initiating
around
monitoring of harpur around the region
so i'll hand on to you adrian because
you know far more about it than i do but
yeah well the sort of harpoo or the sort
of the river
the sort of ponded river mouths of many
of our big braided rivers
are increasingly becoming a focus for
our work
and certainly in two in two areas one
um you may be aware in the wipra
and haranui rivers and things where
we're installing
sort of level loggers water quality
loggers and things to start to
understand those
dynamic areas a little bit more it's got
parallels with what we've maybe
been talking about in the kaiapoi river
as well to sort of start acknowledging
those
we're also um this summer proposing to
do some fish surveys down at some of our
river mouths and this is likely to
extend for the next three or four years
we'll be starting on the big braided
rivers down on the
rangotata the ashburton and the rikaya
but then probably in the second year
moving north into waimakariri ashley
haranui and things like that as well
but really to sort of update they
haven't really been surveyed for their
fisheries
um populations for maybe 30 or 40 years
we get a lot of comment on that and
therefore we're trying to make a start
on that of monitoring the fish
populations
of those harpur or eastern areas
to sort of see what the state they're in
compared to when they were last
comprehensively surveyed 30 or 40 years
ago
and really it's what that's flagging is
that it's they're increasingly coming on
to our work programs to look at that
and i think that's in keeping with where
some of the words in the national policy
statement is sort of
encouraging us to look at that
connectiveness to the sea
and just to be absolutely certain for
everybody here that when we talk about
fish we're talking about
multiple species we're not just talking
about trout and salmon we're
talking particularly in fact
particularly about
native species
shellfish um and then initially we look
we're looking at the the fish the
swimming fish
but inherently we're also while we're
there looking at the habitat which is
the sediment
the the algae and things like that and
inherently we'll be looking at the
shellfish probably as well
as you know that'll broaden out what's
what's the state of those environments
i don't i once again i don't i don't
think we're closing off any avenue to
sort of report on those environments but
it's starting from a fish in a water
quality perspective and it'll move on
from there
and um it's a really good question
because part of what we're doing
is exploring what monitoring is really
needed in these spaces
so that you know we're sort of doing
some scoping and then out of that we can
go
okay we need to do this more regularly
with these parameters
and shellfish may well be part of that
thank you gents oh no
very informative anything else under
general business
right i've got one small item i thought
i'd bring up um
because i think as a very close
working group we formed quite a strong
team here at the waimakariri zone
committee
um and one of our members might be
putting a hand up to join
another team that needs propping up at
the moment so um
megan do you want to comment at all on
that
uh i obviously everyone has uh read the
news i
am the national party's new candidate
for regutar uh so i
am very busy juggling both my council
roles and that
role uh for the next i don't know how
many weeks i've got left six
seven weeks um so very busy i am still
doing
council stuff uh but the best way to get
hold of me at the moment is
by phone usually late evening uh or very
early morning if anyone wants to get in
touch um
but i will pick up the phone i am still
attending council meetings albeit not
all council briefings and trying to keep
abreast of
as much as i can as as we move forward
uh but other than that yeah it's um it's
just a bit of a busy time
at the moment um you know sometimes life
throws up opportunities
that um you've just got to grab and go
with so that's what i've done
cool i'm sure we wish you well
yep all right anything else
stephen could you close the meeting for
us please with the character
thank you very much all right so uh the
next meeting will be
held on the fifth of october
not sure where we'll see there's going
to be there's going to be here right
hopefully not under level two so safe
travels and
look after each other thank you